[Music]
[Applause]
justin herbert back on the program
coming off uh well what's been a pretty
good start for the
chargers so far they got the ravens
coming up which leads me to the obvious
question how much did you watch of the
ravens last night justin
yeah i watched the entire game but uh
first off thanks for having me back
again um it's always a pleasure okay
what do you take do you watch the
offense you watch the defense there and
you take notes
you watch the entire game um it's kind
of different than the film you watch
just because of the camera angles but uh
whatever you can watch whatever you can
pick up during the game um
i think is a bonus but uh to be able to
go back and watch it later uh the
following day i think helps even more
you're listed as a dual threat
quarterback
so is lamar jackson
do you feel like you're a dual threat
when you see lamar jackson out there on
the field
i do not have the same skill set
[Laughter]
you're a good runner
lamarr just seems like he might be just
a little better runner than you uh lamar
is quicker faster
but do you try not to run
um i think running is an important job
of the quarterback position and and
obviously not taking hits too because i
think your ability is your availability
um as long as we're doing our job and
you can extend plays and convert third
and fourth downs i think using the
quarterback's legs i think that's a huge
part of our offense but i wonder though
when you go through your progressions
probably when you're in college you may
not have gone through everything you
just take off and run and rely on your
athleticism but in the nfl
you might be fast but those guys on the
other side of the ball are pretty fast
too so
like you have to have a clock in your
head or a reminder of
go through your progressions and then
take off
yeah that's one of those things that uh
our coach our quarterback coach last
year pep hamilton i we talked about the
entire time and as soon as i got here he
said everyone on defense is faster than
you and as soon as you realize that
getting the ball out quickly and going
through your reads is the most important
job sometimes the pocket does break down
where there's a lane that splits and you
can find it
but other than that it's all about
getting the ball out quick and finding
your completions but when you
you learn to slide playing baseball i'm
gonna guess
yeah correct okay but because there are
a few quarterbacks that have never
learned to slide you and kyler murray
and russell wilson seem to be pretty
good because you played baseball some of
these other guys they have no idea how
to slide
it's not an easy thing to do um i think
just having grown up playing baseball
ever since i was in kindergarten i feel
like that's just a natural thing and you
know and kyler and russell i'm sure they
played baseball growing up and
it's one of those things that i think
you just learned to do and definitely
something you have to spend time on if
you haven't played baseball what is it
about the month of october i i don't
know if you know these numbers since
last season in games played in the month
of october 17 touchdowns one
interception
tied for the most touchdowns fewest
interceptions among starting
quarterbacks in that month you're tied
with
tom brady
that's a that's a pretty good guy to be
in the conversation with
but you know i kept saying don't get
your hair cut because your stats are
going to drop off and that was last year
i mean you paid the price i hope you
learned your lesson i did i uh i know
we've talked about that plenty of times
and uh i won't make the same mistake
take me back to when you're in grade
school and you said you're going to be a
professional quarterback and you're
going to live in los angeles like first
of all is that true
and if so how did you come to that
conclusion so young in your life
it is true i think the more impressive
thing is for my mom to to have kept that
piece of paper um from
elementary school and she probably could
have looked at it and said you know this
we're not going to keep this but uh she
ended up keeping it and we looked back
at it and um you know i think it's just
one of those awesome things where if you
put your mind to it you can do anything
and uh it kind of worked out pretty well
pretty well just so you know you're not
a parent yet but when you are you know
your wife will keep everything just so
you know all those little i got
valentine's day cards from my i kept
everything
so that kind of thing if my son wrote
down he wanted to be the quarterback for
the packers i would have kept it and
then i would have embarrassed him the
whole time when i real when he realized
he was not an athlete so yes mom does
keep all of those things so and
thankfully she did
yeah that's uh that's good to know
though because uh that was definitely a
long time ago so
what do you do on a day off
uh watch film uh the quarterbacks will
come in and lift and then right after
that we'll watch film for a couple of
hours yeah but that's not a day off
though justin
um
technically it kind of is our day off
but you know you have to use all the
time that you can to to get advantage
and get ahead of the schedule because we
don't have a whole lot of time during
the day and especially during the week
so anytime that we can get we got to use
yeah but isn't there part of you that
goes i gotta i gotta take a break from
this
um
i think you could look at it that way i
think i love football enough that i
don't really ever want to get away from
it and i i think
when i do have off time i think that's
kind of
the tough part is is i need something to
do i need to watch football i need to
play football so it's kind of weird like
that but play golf like a day that you
just do video games like you you tell
coach hey
uh i'm gonna take a personal day and go
play golf or something does it work that
way um i don't i don't think so i think
maybe if you've if you've got 15 20
years in the league but
not yet whose posters did you have on
your wall growing up
um i had a joey harrington one from
oregon okay that makes sense i still
have that in my room so um
wait in los angeles you have the joey
hurricane back home oh okay i didn't
know you brought you brought joey
anybody else any other quarterbacks
um
no i think that was the only one i think
that was a uh
a picture of him scoring on a
quarterback throwback and i think an
early bowl game in maybe 2002 against
texas i can't remember which game it was
but
now you talked about you knew you wanted
to be a professional quarterback when
did you know you wanted to be oregon's
starting quarterback
um
i
grew up being an organ fan so maybe
as soon as i knew what football was
kindergarten first second grade
we started going to all these organ
games and my parents would always take
me and that was kind of always the goal
whether that was realistic at the time i
didn't know
i think as soon as i got to high school
and started playing and uh kind of
started to get some attention i kind of
realized that maybe it was a little more
realistic than i thought he's the
chargers quarterback justin herbert the
chargers just beat the browns and uh he
threw for four touchdowns also ran for
another one
how do you explain that fourth quarter
we've we've watched it a couple times
we've talked about it i don't know it to
put up 34 points in the second half like
that and uh it really was a shootout
more of like a college football game
kind of than we imagined
but i thought it was great for our
offense to be able to answer so many
times and you know sometimes that's the
nfl and sometimes you're going to give
up six points and sometimes you're gonna
give a lot of points and it's all about
complimenting the other side of the ball
and i thought it was a win by all three
phases uh on sunday did you say hello to
miles garrett at all because that
defensive front usually is pretty
ferocious there yeah i talked with him
after the game he is tough to block he
is about as special as it gets and uh
the combination of speed toughness
agility um there's no one else like him
can you hear those guys coming
um
no i think everything calms down so much
noise-wise that it's it's more all
visual and and sometimes you just feel
it and uh you know you've got maybe one
or two seconds in the pocket before it
collapses so uh it's definitely a tough
tough situation explain that feel that
you have to have in the pocket because
we we look at guys like you know brady
just it's a little movement here here
there like how is that something learned
or is it just something in your dna
yeah i think it is something you can
learn i think it's a lot of a lot of
experience and feeling that uh the
leverage of the defender and sometimes
with those quick movements like you
mentioned you can buy
just enough time to be able to get the
throw off and i think that's what tom
brady's been so good at is he's got such
a great feel in the pocket that he's
able to step up avoid the rush
and get the ball out on time
what's been the biggest improvement for
you
um i think understanding the offense and
and learning about defenses has have
been huge this offseason i've spent a
lot of time with shane day chase daniel
and easton state just talking about
defenses on our offense and having a
good feel for it
so that when we go out on sunday
you can recognize the coverage see the
fronts you can see everything and not
spend too much time worrying about it i
mentioned this earlier when it comes to
quarterbacks and how you process you
have to do everything and you get like
15 or 20 seconds
send the play in maybe send two plays in
get to the line of scrimmage you got to
call out coverage i mean you gotta
can you explain that just let people
understand
that it's not as easy as it appears to
be and give me real time getting the
play or plays and then what happens
yeah so everything is signaled in
through the radio in our helmet um and
then you repeat the play and sometimes
they get pretty long and so those are
your stuff that you've got to study all
week and 15 16 word calls
are definitely tough but
you go into the huddle you repeat the
play tell everyone what to do you break
the huddle you see the coverage whether
you have any run tags or kills or alerts
you you got to be ready for those
but you get up to live scrimmage you run
the play um and then you then you do the
whole thing again okay give me a complex
play it just it just called in and what
what's it gonna be
uh last year we'd we'd go fleet right
335 max
fc dag uh kill
you know you just you can throw on
whatever you want they get pretty long
um it's just stuff you got to really
study
anybody ever looked at you and not known
what you're talking about in the huddle
no everyone else has been really good
sometimes i've messed up
[Laughter]
wait
how's that happen that you don't know
what you're talking about
there's just so many plays and and you
got to worry about so much and sometimes
you you mess up like whether it's a tag
to the z or the f and so sometimes the
words just get split up in your mind so
it's tough
your headset ever go out
uh a couple times and so that's when you
just have to go with a play that you
know everyone can run and depending on
the personality how you have out on the
field uh you got to make a split
decision
do you practice quarterback sneaks
um we do actually so we've we've
actually talked a lot about that and
with joe lombardi he's kind of talked a
lot about how drew brees has done it and
he's been really successful over the
years so we've kind of implemented a lot
of things that he's been able to do and
brady
i mean he scores all of it he's the king
of the sneak
yeah it's uh it's a really tough play to
stop and to be able to stop that stop
the run and stop the play action pass um
it's not an easy job but when you go up
to the line of sc you go up to your
center do you tap him on the right or
left cheek if if you're going to do a
quarterback sneak
um it's kind of known which direction we
kind of talk about that uh the prior to
the game oh okay okay okay so i don't
want you to give away secrets here that
when you go to the line of scrimmage and
you're tapping your uh center on the
cheek there
uh do people recognize you in la
um i don't really spend too much time
outside of uh you know the building in
my house and um it hasn't really been
too much of an issue i don't think
people care too much about it but wait
do you have any fun
football's fun go showing up here to the
building every day spend
i i could imagine that i could find some
fun in la that it might not be my home
in my office
yeah fortunately we're about an hour
south of la so you know we're kind of
separated in um you know i think it's a
great area that we're in and being able
to spend it with the teammates and all
this responsibility that we have uh we
have to be held accountable so staying
safe uh congrats uh i like you're you're
a nerd you're a grinder yeah you know
you're you're doing all the right things
there and uh and don't try to match
lamar you know run for run okay
uh i'll do my best i'm gonna get down
i'm not gonna take any hits and and
that's
slide slide just remember slide my
chargers uh great to talk to you again
justin thank you very much and uh
congrats
awesome thank you again that's uh justin
herbert i have my oregon ducks and my uh
la chargers there